they were the moments that rocked us the
moments that shocked us this place is
like bunkers right now these are the
biggest bachelor bombshells of 2018 it's
time for roses and rosy hi everybody i'm
lauren zima and i have adorned myself in
my rose blankets because we have to be
all about the complete horrifying
wonderful fabulous best of the worst
worst of the best summary of bachelor
2018 that we are talking about right now
and so for that I just wanted to be
covered in roses guys that we are here
to break down the 13 biggest bachelor
bombshells of the year so you know what
I might as well I just need to I need to
get myself some more wine right now we
have a rosy colored background in this
video I like that it's just how I like
my rose a the lightest of pink
borderline translucent remember that
when you're doing your holiday
gift-giving rose' is not just for summer
it's year-round okay by the way guys
want to know if you agree with our list
so leave your comments in the comment
section and tell us anything we left off
I've had you know a couple glasses
already probably so it's feasible that I
forgot something anything that shouldn't
have been on the list the moment wasn't
as shocking as you thought let me know
okay let's get to it and I'm gonna drink
for each moment please drink responsibly
number 13 been Higgins's winter games
and a meltdown yes you remember bachelor
Winter Games he was the show we didn't
see coming but you know we liked having
even though it was a lot a bachelor to
watch in one week as much as I love this
show we had two hours of re and four
hours of vwg each week and what was also
a lot was been Higgins's breakdown
remember he was in tears talking to the
king of sit downs Chris Harrison about
his ex Lauren Bush now shocking take a
look nobody realizes how real it was
they say did you really love her did you
really care actually get emotional
Oh drink for every tear
[Music]
that's dangerous Wow I didn't see that
coming and I don't think Ben did either
I thought he was gonna go on winter
games and be like cash and fun or hit
the slopes you know he lives in Denver
he knows how to ski and then things took
a turn he ended up leaving early Wow
by the way I recently spoke to Ben on
the phone and things I haven't gotten
much better in his dating life since
then he said he's only really dated two
women kind of since splitting from
Lauren all our love to Ben next up
number 12 Ashley and Jarrod are a real
couple dot dot dot and even engaged yes
cheers to ashley iock and eddie and
jared haben even never says me but
you're just Haven I said hi Ben drink
for both ways of saying it these two
pleasantly surprised and shocked
everybody with the bombshell that they
were actually a couple and that it was
serious it was like after years of being
friends on and off of love us and even
Ashley dating a Canadian they made
things work realized the errors of their
ways Jarrod in particular got it
together he has told me he owns what he
did wrong and owns that he didn't see
the love of his life before well now he
and Ashley are engaged set to be married
in 2019 a bombshell that was a rom-com
she'll Congrats to the two of them we
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
number eleven Garrett's Instagram
scandal Garrett I don't know how to say
his last name and put it up on the
screen you devotion
Garrett sure et Goshen Beca COO friends
fiance became much talked about before
we even knew much about him on her
season because old Instagram likes that
he'd made were discovered he'd liked
some offensive memes and things and
Garrett after a period of silence
ultimately apologized and ultimately got
engaged to Becca kufran the two seem
very happy now people who know Garrett's
say he's the nicest and the sweetest
but wow oh wow did that turn into a
shocker because not only do you like
those memes but he was the guy in Lee
[Music]
number ten
Colton's virgin reveal long before he
over a predatory
this glass I love a big it is it's like
I want to put my whole head into it I
can't believe what if I could I just got
was a my forehead it's fine
okay makeup artists won't care at all
sorry l anyway she did a red lip for me
today for this video okay
so Colton long before he was our
bachelor he was on The Bachelorette it
almost seems hard to remember at this
point doesn't it guys like so much just
happens in son paradise and it's like
2018 the Olympics were this here wow I
still AM I am a virgin
really golden reveal that he was a
full-on virgin on Becca kufran season of
The Bachelorette and he was about 26
years old at the time it was a bombshell
there had never been a male virgin on
the show before I know you're gonna
bring up Sean Lowe here's the thing Sean
Lowe is a born-again virgin for
religious reasons Colton has never had
sex that's the difference okay okay
great
we're good so what a moment I mean of
course you'll remember it was amplified
by the scene in which Colton told Becca
because it looks like that could excuse
herself there was some silence and it
was awkward Becca took to Twitter to say
she just had to go to the bathroom who
wouldn't have to pee in a weird moment I
would need a moment I have to pee all
the time such a small bladder anyway TMI
okay number nine grocery store Joe on
Dancing with the Stars yes this was a
bombshell guys because here's the thing
no bachelorettes since Trista and not
every bachelor lead get to be on Dancing
with the Stars so it was pretty
surprising when grocery store Joe a dude
from night one who granted did make much
a bigger of a show on bachelor in
paradise
but he was fine Dancing with the Stars
what what Wow
and you know what once I found out the
rest of the cast it made sense because
it wasn't the biggest list of a list or
the show's ever had I will say that it's
a very like a DiNozzo it's an advance I
guess this is the bits of better
dedicate and other are you perhaps an
even bigger shocker Jill made it almost
all the way to the very end there and I
congratulate him because he is fun and
he is a sweetie and it was fun to watch
and having Kendall are still together at
the timing of this video I hope nothing
changes number eight back to Colton
Colton is our bachelor yes this was a
bit of a bombshell because a lot of
people were predicting Jason since he
had become a fan favorite or Blake since
he had been really brokenhearted by
Becca but in the end after a dramatic
summer in Paradise where he shed as many
tears as the ocean rolled out waves
Colton Underwood was named our bachelor
and I am good to go with it I know that
some of you feel differently feel free
to speak out in the comments hmmm
getting hot in these blankets but I
won't take them off I won't do it you
need to be adorned to neurosis no other
part of my advocate is showing
this is gonna Wow yep number seven
Bachelor that actually makes sense
because something went down bachelor
producer gone from the show yes on the
same day that Colton Underwood's women
were revealed by Chris Harrison bachelor
creator Mike Fleiss tweeted that
longtime top producer Ilan Dale would no
longer be working with the show okay I
did some digging on this one and a
source tells me that Ilan had been
considering leaving the show for a while
and had been prioritizing other things
working on other projects along with the
bachelor and that Mike had kind of been
seeing that so at the end of the day
this was a fairly mutual parting of the
ways but there was also a bit of tension
about what was being focused on so I
think it was
something that made sense for everybody
and you know what there's a lot of
amazing producers on that show can't
wait to see what they come up with next
including the producer in that moment
with Colton where he cries in the
trailer that's on our list but should it
have been I'm already questioning my own
list let me know in the comments below I
[Music]
have this well my red lips really popped
in here today I have no makeup on oh is
a question Papa can you hear me
I don't know can you find any way next
up number six Kaitlyn and Shawn's split
this was a rough one everybody and it
was a bombshell that maybe we've seen
coming a little bit because there had
been rumors and instagram-stalking about
whether or not they were liking each
other's posts are going to things
together with each other but anyway
Kaitlyn Bristowe and Shawn booth split
up after several years of being engaged
after he proposed on the show they were
one of the most beloved couples in the
franchise I think they're both lovely
people Caitlyn especially she is just
one of my very favorite if not my
favorite bachelorettes so man oh man
this was a bombshell of a bummer wasn't
it but all the best to both of them and
wishing Kaitlyn just all the love in the
world I hope that she finds someone who
deserves her funny kind of lovely word
oh by the way you know what if you guys
have people ship Kaitlyn with let me
know in the comments anybody from
bachelor nation who we'd like to see
Kaitlyn date let me know in the comments
below
I was really pointing at my wine
[Music]
you know I've said before in these
videos that I don't like puppies I'm
sorry guys but I'm not the biggest baby
person either but this is like my child
I have big news in 2019 I am expecting
more Rosie
that seamless trout there look at the
way I'm supporting the neck anyway
numbers 5 4 3 & 2 are all to do with re
number 5 re dumped his fiancee Becca
kufran in an unedited scene from the
show but he would later argue was edited
but Becca would stand by the fact that
it wasn't edited Ari's definition of
edit was a little bit up in the air
confusing
whatever he proposed to her they got
engaged and then he dumped her it was
wild
wasn't it caught that seems like so long
ago number four on the season finale of
his season a hurry after everyone had
just watched that footage which created
was a couple weeks old but we had just
watched it I'm gonna pass out after we
just watched him dump Becca re-proposed
live on television - Lauren Burnham
Congrats question mark what a moment
number three Arie and Lauren revealed
just as Becca season is about to start
that they will be getting married in
January 2019 yes not every couple from
this franchise goes out and walks down
the aisle for real so are you Lauren
really getting married really doing it
that's a bombshell and number two they
might not get married till 2019 but we
already know first comes baby ari and
Lauren revealed that she is expecting
their first child so when they get
married she will be carrying an extra
little one at the altar all my love to
them truly I will take any couple that
can make it from this franchise even
being honest I know that I've expressed
some issues with Ari in the past and I
still have those issues but I think
Lauren is a real sweetheart I want her
to be happy I want the two of them to be
happy and let's start 2019 fresh love
and bombshells and everyone well our
number one bombshell of 2019 you know
what it is Jordan and Jenna and
everything I didn't even know how to
fully summarize the Jordan and Jenna
scandal of bachelor in paradise 2018 but
let's just try to CliffsNotes the
insanity of it all Jordan and Jenna are
an unlikely couple out of paradise
didn't really see it coming
done it's very fun that's just the dress
then on the towel they talk about their
wedding date its plans they're ready
didn't really see it coming then just
after the tell-all
it comes out that Jenna allegedly /
alleged text messages cheated on Jordan
and after that the wild wild west
bachelor in paradise world becomes a
reality Jordan and Jenna split up Jenna
hires a legal team she says she's going
to do some forensic analysis on her
phone and at the end of The Bachelor day
Jenna claims that Jordan is the one
behind all the rumors
[Applause]
tell me something is forensic evidence
what you're looking for we're falling
into the clickbait of these headlines
and we're on board with a full and
detailed timeline Jana in Jordan what
happened to their Lobby is out the
window
aho
[Music]
yes from the depths all the way up to
the shallow we don't know what happened
there and you guys I'm not sure we will
ever get real legit credible fact
answers on the Jenna in Jordan situation
but at the end of the day we love The
Bachelor we're always kept guessing
wondering questioning adoring and 2019
promises more big bachelor bombshells to
come cold an Underwood season premieres
January 7th on ABC with a three-hour
live show what do you guys think how is
this list 13 moments I might have as I
said forgotten something I've been
drinking something and now I have to
bring in one of our favorite bachelor
critics jay-z come on in pal JC what was
the bachelor moment from this year that
you will not forget the unedited re Beca
breakup mm-hmm and why that was intense
that took a lot of bachelor cojones oh
oh nice yeah to do that on television
for both of them you know to allow that
to be comfortable with that being shown
to be able to do the breakup on TV like
that and you know for Becca to show the
example of rising up when life hands you
Bachelor lemons while you drink some
Rose a first but then you do some
Bachelor lemonade and that's why we love
JC everybody because even in that crazy
moment with Ari he's spotlights the
woman in the situation the lovely Becca
JC a champion for us all the good guys
all right everyone that has been the
biggest bachelor bombshell moments of
2018 again let us know if we forgot some
moments or if you disagree with the
order or if you just love the order and
think we did a great freaking job I love
you guys so much
tweet me message me anytime
cannot wait to do closing season with
you all May
[Music]